So the two questions we’re going to talk about now
are what are my revenue streams? And next, within
the revenue streams, how do I price the product.
So let’s take a look, what exactly is a revenue
stream. A revenue stream is the strategy the
company uses to generate cash from each
customer segment. So if you have multiple
customer segments, you may have multiple
revenue streams. We’ll go into this in some
detail. But let’s define pricing. Pricing are
the tactics you use to set the price. How
many dollars or pounds or is it free in
each of these customer segments.
So now let’s go back and look at the revenue
stream in some detail. First couple of questions
you need to answer is number one what
value are customers willing to pay for. How
do you know this? Well on day one you’re
just sitting in your building or in you
class room or in your lab, and you are guessing.
You’re going, hey these are my customers,
guess. You know, these are the features they
care about. Guess. This the value they’re going
to pay for. Guess. But by now you’ve been in
front of a ton of customers. You’ve talked
to them just extensively, and you understand
what it is they value. And that’s what we’re
going to use to figure out what the revenue
streams and pricing are. The next thing that
you actually found out outside the building
was how do customers pay for products today.
Also you want to understand how much are
they paying. So, how do they pay and how
much do they pay. So, well, for big picture,
let’s go take a look at the revenue stream
choices at the highest possible level.